We have made a new material
it's a material that has never existed
on earth before:
metallic hydrogen.
Hydrogen is the simplest atom in the
periodic table of the elements, it consists
of a single proton with the single
electron around it, at room temperature, it
exists as a gas but if you cool hydrogen
down to low temperatures it actually
liquefies and if I cool it to about just under
14 degrees it forms a solid. Imagine my
fingers are molecules here with the two
atoms, if you compress it to a high
enough density eventually you will get
to a pressure or a density where the
molecules dissociate and it forms an
atomic solid and this is a metal.
You have two diamonds sitting opposite to each
other inside here we load the sample as a
liquid state, but as soon as you pressurize
it, the molecules get closer together it becomes
a solid, and then we're squeezing the
solid, and even though this device looks
very small we can generate pressure
more than the center of earth.
You never know how it's going to be
applied but imagine that it's metastable
and you can make electrical wires out of
it, you could conduct electricity across
the country without dissipation, you
could make magnets which are used in MRI,
for example, that would work at room
temperature. Right now the magnets have
to be cooled with liquid helium. NASA has
supported some of our research because
it turns out that if it's metastable and
you could cause it to convert to molecular
hydrogen, it releases an enormous
amount of energy and it would
revolutionize rocketry and it's a very
nice thing to achieve.